wie ist die Lage ja entschuldige
entschuldigen Sie die
[Musik]
Frage Schnauze
Interview kann er gleich gleich kann er
auch das tut mir so leid weil als in dem
Alter W ich das auch so gerne mal machen
und dann kommen gleich die Onkels ja wie
ist die Lage Entschuldigung die Frage
wie ist den die Lage t kein schit auf
den haen und ein Blick auf die Wage aber
wir mögen es Funny vbucks Bunny so ist
die Lage ein Zitat aus dem neuen Stück
Smudo in Zukunft von der neuen Platte
für ich mir noch Fantasie von den
Fantastischen
Vier was sagt uns denn dieser Satz die
Lage ist sehr gut wir spielen heute zum
dritten Mal in Dortmund wir haben
gestern zum zweiten Mal in Dortmund
gespielt und vorgestern zum ersten Mal
also heute praktisch die Premiere
gestern war die Vorpremiere und davor
war die Probe und jetzt sind wir fit ab
heute Abend dann auch die großen
Festivals zu rocken mit den neuen Songs
der alten Band den gleichen fandas fühlt
sich gut an gerade das ist meine Frage
was habt ihr jetzt so für ein Gefühl
neue Platte raus Gott se dan neue Platte
raus genug Retrospektive die letzten
zwei Jahre gewesen mit Heimspiel und 20
Jahre fantaf war schön ein wahnsinns
Konzert unser 20-jähriges Bühnenjubiläum
in Stuttgart vor den 60.000 Leuten war
der Hammer aber es war echt sehr nervig
immer nur von früher zu reden und halt
nur die alten Stücke zu spielen jetzt
sind wir e neue Platte draußen zu haben
die Stücke auch auf die Bühne zu bringen
und Spaß mit neu Musik zu haben die
meisten Musiker die sagen ja wenn eine
neue Platte rauskommt das ist meine
beste
Platte unsere unsere beschissenste
Platte die wir je gemacht
haben aber was willst du machen ist klar
sagt jeder Musiker dass die neue die
beste Platte ist weil sie einfach am
neuesten ist und weil das einfach so das
Baby ist dass man jetzt gerade im Moment
so am liebsten hat und hatschelt und im
Arm herumträgt ähm es lässt sich
natürlich erstmal mit paar Jährchen
Abstand sagen
wie die Platte dann nachhaltig wirkt
aber wir haben ein ziemlich gutes Gefühl
damit also ihr könnt sie jetzt von euch
aus noch nicht so in euer Gesamtwerk
einsortieren nee meistens dauert's zwei
Jahre bis man eine Platte dann etwas
neutraler oder so im Verhältnis zu den
anderen Platten betrachten kann und aber
auch dann
ähm ist der Eindruck nicht objektiv er
bleibt immer subjektiv hängt auch
zusammen mit der Zeit die man damals
hatte hier einige von uns z.B mich ein
inbegriffen geben der viel oder der 499
eher schlechtere Noten es stimmt aber
auch überhaupt nicht denn auf eine der
beiden war glaub MFG drauf z.B Wahnsinn
Song also man tut der Platte dann auch
Unrecht wenn man sagt nee die war nicht
so gut es gibt aber Highlights natürlich
auch für mich persönlich dass die vierte
Dimension und Lauschgift und nachdem ich
ein groß Fan von fornica war und bei
dieser Platte hier für dich immer noch
Fantasie am Anfang sehr skeptisch da
wäre auch zwei Jahre dran gearbeitet
haben über 300 musikalische Samples
angehört probiert verworfen neu gemacht
und der ganze Prozessen sehr langer war
empfand ich den Anfang als etwas zäh und
es hat ein bisschen gedauert bis ich Fan
davon wurde und das hat sich dann aber
gesteigert und jetzt stehe ich da und
denke das ist eine der drei geilsten
Platten die wir je gemacht haben warum
geht das bei euch noch
die meisten Ehepaare lassen sich
wenn man so lange ist zusammen ist
scheiden ween man irgendwas passieren
Verwerfung man hat sich schon mal
verletzt warum geht das bei euch noch
warum könnt warum vertragt ihr euch das
liegt an der Zwangsehe die ist ja
abgeschafft worden aber wir sind ja von
unseren Eltern zusammen praktisch
fürüreinander bestimmt worden und können
da halt nicht mehr raus wir haben es nie
gelernt zu sagen Tschüss sagen jeden Tag
erneut hallo hallo Fantas hallo Band
hallo Leben
mm es gibt natürlich jetzt so
Geheimnisse die gar keine sind getrennte
Schlafzimmer getrennte Wohnorte
getrennte Frauen
oder also eben nicht die gleichen
Geschlechtspartner sowas hilft bei so
einer Männer
ehe die in Deutschland ja immer noch
glaube ich ist die jetzt anerkannt
mittlerweile so eine Vierer männere Ehe
Vierer noch nicht Gott sei Dank aber
glaub ich n aber könnt ja zwei zweier
immerhin schon mal kan dann so eine
gruppenparung veranlassen geht aber dann
doch nicht weil wir haben ja schon
Frauen heiraten also du nicht wollen
können du könntest uns jetzt adoptieren
genau ich der P und der PAP der ist es
doch also gut so machen wir aber bis
dahin kann man sagen am
Anfang will man dass alle so sind wie
man selber ja das die Lösung eurer
Probleme denkt ihr wenn wenn alle so
wären wie ich da hätten wir keine
Probleme mehr da hatten wir auch diese
Phase hät uns
fast hat auch viel Probleme da hatten
Probleme und dann merkst du ich GT einen
ganz entscheidenden Moment in der
Karriere der Fantastischen 4 ausgelöst
durch ein Selbstmordversuch von meinem
Hund der es nicht mehr ausgehalten hat
diese diese Spannung Hunde sind ja sehr
sensibel und dann gerettet durch einen
Satz von Miro ich sagte Jungs
Sitz
Platz
genau wir wissen doch alle nicht wie es
geht keiner weiß wie die perfekte Band
bzw der perfekte Song die perfekte
Platte ist nur indem wir zusammen
produktiv an diesem Ding Arbeiten ich
glaube ich habe damals so ein so ein
klischeesatz gesagt wie wir sitzen alle
in einem Boot und so weiter sie wissen
schon dieses Beispiel der Ozean ist groß
und voll mit Haien und wir können nur
wenn wir in eine Richtung Rudern das
Ding noch reißen und das ist der
Schlüssel zum Geheimnis der
Fantastischen Vier wir sind alle sehr
unterschiedlich und diese
Unterschiedlichkeit wertzuschätzen und
sie als Bereicherung zu empfinden das
ist auch der Schlüssel unserer Ehe
unserer Gemeinschaft weil wir nicht mehr
wollen dass alle so sind wie ich sondern
wir wollen alle so sein wie der
Michi können sie aber nicht aber wir
akzeptieren auch dass wir es nicht
können nein tatsächlich wirklich wichtig
ist loslassen ich glaube nicht nur in
einer bandbeziehung sondern duhaupt in
einer Beziehung und den anderen sein
Ding machen lassen dieses los lassen
auch eben sich trennen und nicht die
Angst haben dass es die B zerfetzt hätte
das passieren können also das Trennen al
loslassen zum zum Trennen als Bedingung
damit man eben wieder zusammen findet
also oder habt in der Phase ihr Angst
dass ihr nie mehr was zusammen macht
eigentlich denken wir seit fünf Platten
das wäre die letzte Platte also die Band
ist immer kurz vor der Trennung gewesen
zur Zeit glaube ich obwohl wir
beschlossen haben mit Schluss zu machen
geht uns gar nicht so
aber in der Regel war es schon immer die
Frage
warum noch mal und wo ist da der Antrieb
denn da wir ja früh schon einen
ziemlichen Erfolg hatten fehlen dann
irgendwann die Ziele die du dir gesteckt
hast als du noch nicht da warst wie ich
will in die Charts oder ich will große
Bühnen spielen und so weiter und dann
hast du das alles gemacht setzt ein
Haken dahinter wo sind die nächsten
Ziele und und dies Ziel muss man immer
wieder neu oder wir immer wieder neu
definieren mit jeder Platte warum eine
neue Platte wer braucht das brauchen das
und warum brauchen wir das wenn wir das
brauchen und das führt das ist ein sehr
spannender Vorgang der dann durch Musik
und durch Texte durch etwas was es ja
auch schon gibt manigfaltig trotzdem
etwas Neues entstehen lässt man nennt
das
Kreativität und in diesem kreativen
Prozess merkst du plötzlich warum du da
bist warum du das machst warum du diesen
Job hast und warum das Sinn macht
weiterzumachen und diese Sinnstiftung
erfährt man immer wenn man halt Musik
macht weil das Gefühl hast geil das ist
einfach sehr schwer zu beschreiben aber
Magic also mir geht es so
dass ich nie ein Haken hinter dieses
Bühne und Platte und so gemacht habe
sondern dass es schon jedes mal geil ist
auf Bühnen zu stehen also live spielen
ist echt super
aber wir sind ziemlich früh immer an
einem Punkt wo
wir uns langweilen auf der Bühne weil
wir das einfach so oft gespielt haben
ich glaube wir sind eine Band die nicht
in
Gefahr läuft so so weathergir mäßig it's
raining man 30 Jahre lang runter Z
spielen und CH Show zu Chart Show genau
weil uns schon nach vier Wochen Tour die
alten Stücke auf dem Sack gehen und wir
echt neu spielen und dann mit mit einer
neuen Platte auf die Bühne zu kommen ist
jedes Mal wie neu die Bühne zu entdecken
und das ist das geile am Musik machen
und am
Musik spielen und dann Platten machen
also mittlerweile ist echt schon fast so
dass dass mir geht es so ich mache neue
Songs und sie dann live spielen zu
können das heißt ihr würdet auch
weiterplatten machen wenn die nur 5000
Stück verkaufen würden z. aufar kein
Fall aber hört sich ja so an uns macht
das Spaß genau wir machen es wegen der
Sache aber einerseits sindmer natürlich
erfolgsverwöhnt wahnsinnig
erfolgsverwöhnt auf der anderen Seite
wenn es uns gefällt dann ist es zwei
angig wie viel Leute kommen und wo es in
den Charts hingeht Zeitlang ist es
zweitrangig ja klar wenn kein Geld mehr
mit Verdienst und irgendwie pleide bist
aber aber musikmchen an sich richtet
sich nicht nach dem Erfolg sondern nur
nach dem der persönlichen irgendwas zu
machen was man noch nicht gemacht hat
was zu sagen was man noch nicht gesagt
hat etwas Neues zu entdecken wo man
denkt man hätte alles schon gesagt und
es gibt alles schon und es ist alles
schon da und dann trotzdem irgendwie
dieses neue erschaffen das ist der
Hauptgrund für mich ja aber müsst ihr
denn noch Musik machen also seid ja eben
schon lange erfolgreich ihr müsst doch
schon eigentlich die Bausparverträge
abgelöst haben also wir müssen natürlich
keine Musik machen wir hätten auch nie
anfangen müssen Musik zu machen wir
hätten auch uns eigentlich mit 10 Jahren
schon umbringen können hätten man auch
alles machen können aber ich find's
komisch gefragt zu werden also
irgendein Bankier oder auch ne Bankier
ist ein schlechtes Beispiel lieber mal
ein ein Filmregisseur oder ein ein
Künstler ein Maler
der wird doch nie gefragt hast du jetzt
nicht genug Bilder gemalt 40 kannst du
mal aufhören Bilder zu malchen oder oder
ein Regisseur wird wird auch auch nicht
gefragt hast du doch schon so viel Film
musst du denn immer noch Film machen
nein das ist zum einen natürlich die
Passion dasjenigen das zu machen zum
anderen auch sein Beruf blöd also
wirklich profan gesagt davon und dafür
leben wir und wir haben nicht vor
aufzuhören zu leben oder jetzt in ren zu
gehen oder uns einfach auf die Wiese zu
legen deswegen machen wir weiter Musik
weil wir uns für dieses Leben
entschieden haben ziemlich früh und
total glücklich darüber sind dass wir
dieses Leben führen können und und es
eigentlich echt auch wichtig ist morgens
aufzuwachen und und sich das zu sagen
wenn du irgendwie auch verkaret im
Hotelbett liegst und denkst was für eine
heftige nachtgestern und anstrengend
dass du dir das seit du 13 oder 12 Jahre
altw erträumt hast dass du es mal machen
kannst und das immer noch machen kannst
und und dein Hobby
äh zum Beruf gemacht hast der dich auch
noch reich dabei macht das ist das
schönste irgendwie was hier passieren
kann aber ich will dir sagen warum die
Frage berechtigt ist weil es ja bei
vielen Künstlern eben genau nicht so ist
die haben Erfolg und dann ist irgendwann
die Luft raus weil das der ein Antrieb
war jetzt kommt meine Theorie sie ist
eine Theorie die natürlich auch auf
persönliche Erfahrung fußt allerdings
sieht smuto ist ein bisschen anders
trotzdem kurz ausführen darf Erfolg ist
a okay heißt so vi wie du hast
kein mach dich fertig du hast ihn und er
macht dich auch fertig und gerade wenn
man nicht so sich selber gern
runterzieht wie wir gegenseitig sich am
Boden hält irgendwie
auch die Höhenflüge deutschlandweit
natürlich begrenzt sind sondern gerade
bei weltweiten Stars wenn dir jeder in
den ins Hinterteil kriegt und nur ja
sage um dich rum hast du die Geld
Maschine geworden bist son es nur noch
wo es gar nicht um dich geht von Anfang
an nicht jeder zweite versteht dich eh
falsch oder keiner versteht dich keiner
weiß wie es wirklich in dir aussieht und
daran zerbrechen viele an diesem Erfolg
weil sie sich selber nicht mehr finden
in diesem in dieser Figur in dieser
Kunstfigur die sie da draußen darstellen
und da haben wir einerseits Glück weil
wir nicht alleine auf dieser Bühne
stehen eine gute gruppeninterne
Psychologie haben Psychohygiene und auf
der anderen Seite weil wir halt eh nur
wie heißen die dachländer
Deutschland Österreich und Schweiz die
die großen sind
und
Deutschland
internänder ich wegen der Schweiz und
österich ja ja das Dach der wel Top of
the World top of
da damit hält sich echt aus das ist
nicht das ist nicht Hollywood ja habt
ihr denn aber das gibt ja auch bei
deutschen Stars habt ihr keine jahsager
um euch herum doch natürlich alle die
nein sagen sind sofort raus nein aber
das ist do so wenn ihr wenn ihr irgendwo
hingeht und euren Freunden oder sonst
aber die sagen nicht
ja wir sind so hart zu uns das
glaubst wir sind so geile neinsage
zueinander und das muss man erstmal
aushalten könen aber andersrum Erfolg
ja aber ich glaube auch es gibt so
viele Musiker die nicht weitermachen
weil sie es nicht drauf haben ja und
entweder also nicht nur am Erfolg
zerbrechen sondern auch an der
Erfolglosigkeit zerbrechen wenn du nicht
hast zerbrichst du dran und wenn du hast
zerbrichst es ist natürlich schon eine
Gradwanderung sich nicht selbst für den
Erfolg aufzugeben weil wenn du das
machst hast du nicht mehr lange Erfolg
und
aber auch nicht alles
gegen den Erfolg zu tun und zu sagen ich
mache nur noch für mich Musik dann
verschwindest du auch und dann machst du
vielleicht Musik für dich im Wohnzimmer
eine Frau die genervt ist und lieber
fernsehen möchte aber diese
Gradwanderung zu gehen ist glaube ich
das spezielle was was nicht viele Bands
oder nicht viele Künstler vielleicht
drauf haben wir vielleicht ja kommt ja
auch in eurer Platte vor dieses Thema
eben von vielen Leuten mit denen i
vielleicht Kontakt habt die sagen kann
ich doch auch ja
ja na ja unsere einfache Regel ist ja es
ist also man kann sie von außen
hinstellen und immer sehr einfach sag
sagen ja fand das das kann ich ja auch
und so na ja aber dann bitte bis
herzlich eingeladen und dann kannst du
mal ausprobieren weil es ist nicht alles
einfach weil wenn alles einfach wäre
können sie da machen und dann gibt's zu
viel und dann gelten die Gesetze des
Marktes nämlich auch weil dann gibt es
zu viel Angebot keine Nachfrage mehr
also ich glaube schon dass das was wir
machen was besonderes ist und ich glaube
dass dass wir neben dem neben den ich
glaubslich eine kernqualität ist dass
wir
daran noch Spaß haben ich GL das ist
glaub ich ein Hauptpunkt ist und deshalb
immer weitermachen auch und woher das
Spaß sich näht das wird bei jedem anders
sein das ist mit sicher auch Erfolg das
muss nicht monetärer Erfolg sein sondern
auch z.B die äh halbnackten Frauen die
Abend helzimmer einrennen z.B oder ähm
glücklich Gesichter diese glücklichen
Gesichter genau die sind wenn sie wieder
rausgegangen sind und äh während des
Konzerts ja natürlich und
oder eben dann aber auch die Tatsache
seine Familie davon vielleicht ernähren
kann und also ganz viele Sachen ich
glaube nicht dass wir glücklich werden
wenn wir es z. gut verkaufen aber
unzufrieden werden mit unserer Arbeit
das glaube ich weren wir sogar sehr
unglücklich damit chuldig kurz ich muss
mal kurz gehen ja
wiedersehenigldig wenn du ich wollte
noch kurz das finde ich auch ein ganz
wichtigen punktb du könntest
uner vier
Wodka fünf
wodkaer ich vergesse das immer
kein Problem kein
Problem was auch noch eine ganz wichtige
Nummer ist bei diesem erfolgsding ist
glaube ich wirklich wenn du dich
verbiegst um Erfolg zu haben
wenn du dich verbiegst um Erfolg zu
haben dann äh und dann hast Du Erfolg
dann wirst du immer sehen dass das ja
nicht du bist ja du bist ja hast ja nur
gemacht um das macht dich kaputt und
wenn du damit kein Erfolg hast bringt
sich doppelt um weil dann weißt Du
nämich verdammt hätte ich so gemacht wie
ich wollte oder wie ich es gefühlt hätte
und wenn du so machst wie du es fühlst
und du hast Erfolg ist es wunderschön
und wenn du kein Erfolg hast ist es so
wie ja und aber ich habe ich habe das
gemacht das ist glaube ich das
Wichtigste wenn man überhaupt da draußen
anfängt in der Öffentlichkeit tätig zu
sein muss deinem Herzen folgen du musst
das machen was du was aus dir rauskommt
weil alles andere wird auch beim
Erfolgsfall nicht gut sein für
dich aber ihr seid wenn ich das so höre
seid ihr dafür auch dankbar oder fühlt
ihr euch sag mal von der Muse geküsst
oder gibt da wie wie wie sortiert
das sag mal du hast es gibt Mantra ein
religiöses Stück es gibt dieses Stück
danke was empfindet ihr da seid ihr so
ist es die Einstellung hey wir sind
großartig oder ist die Einstellung
lieber Gott danke dass du uns dieses
Talent gegeben hast oder es ist die
Einstellung wir sind großartig vielen
Dank dass wir großartig
sind es
ist schwer zu sagen ich find schon das
eine Dankbarkeit da auf jeden Fall wir
sind privileged
blessed happy
soll man das sagen JA aber das ist schon
also manmal kotzt S auch an und es nervt
Dich aber insgesamt darf man nicht
vergessen dass wir den besten Job der
Welt haben bei uns ist glaube ich eine
interessante Mischung aus
Überheblichkeit und Selbstzweifeln die
sich ständig abwechs abwechseln das sind
unsere er and Downer Endorphine die die
unseren Motor am am Brennen halten auf
jeden Fall ich glaub das ist auch
bezeichnen dass man das Mittelmaß nicht
kennt oder nicht haben will wenn man
so Künstler ist oder wie auch immer der
Lebenskünstler dass man entweder es ist
wahnsinnig geil oder es ist absolut
scheiße aber Mittelmaß ist mir z.B kenne
ich nicht ist mir
fremd in diesem Sinne vielen Dank danke
schön